[Music]
these teenagers mostly come from Muslim
families in veal voda a municipality
north of Brussels they feel United as a
group and it's on a football pitch that
they feel at home hey stop talking to
the journalists they only make us look
bad stop filming right now but
eventually some of them did speak to us
they told us how their group feels torn
apart as recently nearly 30 teenagers
left field water for Syria enlisted by
extremists that's terrible
I know some of them it's really sad they
could come back dead I'm against them
going to Syria Mahad knows almost all
the guys who went to Syria he was able
to resist the false prophets his parents
faithful Muslims taught him that there
cannot be a holy war the guys really
believed that they had to fight for them
jihad is an ideal and they wanted to
follow it the Imams and Belgian mosques
have lost a lot of influence with
teenagers in the suburbs by using the
internet they now want to offer guidance
and prevent hate preachers from enticing
today's youth we're active on Facebook
our teachers of the Quran asked their
students to talk with those who've been
radicalized to counter their arguments
and to show them that Islam is a
religion of peace and love in attica
Muslims on the other hand don't argue or
debate to lower teenagers the group
sharia4belgium uses a wildly doubtful
prophecy that one day the
youth will be the administrators of an
Islamist state in Belgium at the moment
more than 40 members of this group are
on trial one of the plaintiffs is
Dimitri bon tink his son Ian was
enlisted by the Sharia group and went to
Syria risking his own life his father
managed to get him back home it's a
story with a happy ending but bond tink
resents how little help he got from the
authorities of course we ask help by the
authorities by the police by youth
organisations and the answer was they
couldn't do something because there was
a freedom of organisation there was
freedom of speech there was freedom of
religion you know they were laughing
with me they took me as a clown you know
what they said to me that is not even my
business to know where is my son
that's excuse me I'm a father this
criticism seems to be justified for
decades the country has been preoccupied
with its own unity issue the scientists
on Clementine Barack says the job of
integrating other cultures has been more
difficult for Belgium than for other
European countries for the last 20 years
Belgium hasn't done enough to fight
radical Islam and now it's a huge
problem one reason is because Belgium is
split between the French and Flemish
parts that form their own strong
autonomous communities it's a
particularly good environment to spread
radical Islam since the failed terrorist
attack a few weeks ago the security
forces are on high alert
police are present everywhere but this
is just the first step for the mayor of
avodah here in valve Horta we need more
schools and more facilities for young
people we need more sports grounds
because I'm certain that sport can
contribute to integration while Andy
Gracie of aussi par Les Paul
we won't see there are reasons behind
the radicalization teenagers didn't just
wake up one morning and think let's just
go to Syria time and again they felt
rejected by the Belgian society there is
a chance to escape the hate preachers
most of the guys in villa vada know that
many of them just dream of
acknowledgment a chance to become part
of Belgian society